welcome back the doctors at
Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this segment want to stress how
important it is to know the signs and
symptoms of a stroke we stop by the
horizons My Generation Clinic that's
senior focused care in Henderson to
learn more what is a stroke uh stroke is
the term that Physicians use to
basically describe damage to the brain
this damage occurs due to blood flow
issues what happens when you have a
stroke
there are several factors the first
Factor being where in the brain the
stroke occurs and how much of the brain
has been affected the second factor is
time and length of the stroke
time and length to treatment most
patients will have zero to no symptoms
after a stroke some patients will have
partial paralyzation and some people
will have speech difficulty
stroke is the number one cause of
disability on the planet and only 40
percent of Americans know how to even
recognize diagnose and what to do for
treatment for stroke here in around we
got an acronym be fast okay B for
balance coordination
do you have any difficulties with
balance and coordination e eyes do you
have any deficits in one or both of your
eyes F facial asymmetry do you have
facial droop a arms legs do you have any
weakness in your extremities s speech do
you have any speech difficulties and T
time how long have these symptoms been
going on the right way to treat a stroke
depends on first what kind of stroke the
patient is having
so it's very crucial that the patient
gets to the hospital as soon as possible
once we get to the PA once we get the
patient to the hospital we can do an MRI
and a CT to determine what kind of
stroke the patient is having something I
want the patients to remember is that
all patients should be able to recognize
and diagnose stroke because the stroke
can happen at any time of any patient's
life that being said there are some risk
factors that can increase your risk of
stroke number one hypertension high
blood pressure number two high
cholesterol number three diabetes Number
Four history of smoking and number five
genetic factors if you have any of the
conditions we just talked about you want
to control these with medicines if you
have hypertension keep your blood
pressure under control if you have
diabetes we want to keep that A1C level
down high cholesterol take your Statin
medication okay if you have a history of
smoking stop smoking okay other things
you can do lifestyle changes you want if
you're overweight you want to lose
weight okay low salt diet keep a
balanced diet preferably a Mediterranean
one one last thing I want the patients
to know is about mini strokes also known
as transient ischemic attacks
these are basically stroke-like symptoms
that last for seconds minutes to an hour
and they totally resolve patients feel
that because this is totally resolved
that they that they don't need to be
evaluated this is a mistake once you
have a mini stroke your risk of having a
stroke increases dramatically and this
patient needs to be evaluated the
Intermountain Health Team of Specialists
has developed protocols that shorten the
amount of time it takes to diagnose and
treat a stroke this is important because
a quick diagnosis and treatment can mean
less long-term damage less disability
and better overall outcomes
thank you to Intermountain Health for
sponsoring this segment for more
information visit intermountainnv.org